whoa I'm sorry I'm so sorry I don't know
what's happening right now is just
coming up and well it's not coming oh my
goodness it's coming yeah and we all
look exactly the same as when we saw
each other a couple seconds ago yeah
well now wait I always wondered what the
last lyric was meow Lloyd was right so
sorry again porns they'll forgive you
stuckman
in time well that's a pretty big
overlook my line Luke tries ignoring her
but her big walking carpet is a little
more forceful I just realized what that
kind of sounds like try try saying the
big walking carpet a better plan is a
little more good Luke still says no but
our two shows them frenching his sister
which gives him the motivation to train
again chef no shows him his frenching
sister I was right it was like our two
played a different night
I'm using it as a different kind of verb
like to record that do you want evil or
efficient well evil of course boy that
would have been a different movie great
I think that's why they pay me the big
bucks you know Matthew project how how
can we trust you if we don't even know
we're doing I need you I forgot my line
my god let's continue discontinued hey I
think that roses sounds like a
restaurant that sweet punk rock
seventies you guys want to fit in roses
Oh Brad says sorry oh well done Holden
you've got us to the planet hauled oh
I'm so sorry hold Oh or is it is I'm
guessing everything I've know what it
means
shut up that's right we're taking over
this ship I'm tired of your orders I'm
tired of listening to you I'm tired of
nuts going on what ways they event I
will try to get I am totally
gonna rule the universe one photo spread
at a time with the occasional
well-written article come with me in
number two under control now where am I
looking down pretty much yeah Rob sighs
yeah look into Rob's gorgeous eyes I
hope it I will look into the camera okay
it turns out Luke has used all of his
powers to project himself from miles
away but it drains all of his literal
lifeforce
should I didn't save miles but it's like
literally planets away several feet away
operation brought him to smithereens was
a smashing success you can even ask him
yourself
[Laughter]
[Music]
look operation broke him to smithereens
with a smashing success do give Adam a
second yeah
look at foreveralone and yes he even
appears to have the force what can I say
he's force sensitive sure and yes he
even appears to be force sensitive and
you're shortly challenged they prefer to
be tough
you